now of course Democrats never let truth
get in the way of a great political lie
and narrative now all of a sudden after
years of tantrums and ripped speeches
they're very concerned with decorum in
the House of Representatives and they're
very angry tonight at congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green one msdnc hosts
whining that she breached to Quorum and
will face no consequences for it
election denier himself Jamie Raskin
calling her ridiculous and brought up
George Santos why don't you bring up the
congenital liar your friend Adam Schiff
it's all they seem to be able to talk
about and meanwhile Chelsea Handler
called her a miserable and the
always classy ladies of the view they
even attacked her wardrobe I didn't know
that they were such fashion experts on
that show but take a look I was
distracted by Marjorie Taylor Green's
jacket oh my God
it lend my puppy yeah
it was like a little Cruella Deville
I could see it now the fashion
collections of joyless Behar anyway here
to respond Georgia congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green is with us uh yeah
I personally loved every moment of it
I'll tell you why because every two and
four years and they did it in this last
election Democrats lie and say that
Republicans want dirty air and water
they want to throw Granny and Grandpa
over a cliff they want to take away
Social Security their racist sexist
homophobic xenophobic transphobic you
know and it goes on so you know the
Republicans in unison and you're pretty
loud you had a seat in the back saying
not true uh what did you think of Joe
Biden engaging that
well I thought it was pretty impressive
that the president would enter the
people's house and try to lie to the
American people about the economy the
border and even ignore the fact that he
allowed the Chinese spy balloon to spy
on America but when he continued the LIE
accusing Republicans of of preparing to
cut Social Security and Medicare we
couldn't take it so I along with my
colleagues were calling him out I think
I was just the loudest one because I
stood up and screamed liar and the
reason why I did that Sean is because
they have used my image and my name is
leading the effort in that when we have
not had one single meeting in the GOP
conference talking about cutting Social
Security and Medicare Joe Biden is a
liar I represent the American people and
I was honored to be able to call him the
liar that he is in the people's house
and not allow him to get away with it do
you have any reaction to the the fashion
experts the fashion icons on The View
well you know I have to say Sean you
know occasionally I get yelled at by old
white women and I always know that
they're they watch The View because
those are some nasty women on that show
and they have no right to to insult
anyone's fashion I was wearing a wool
coat actually and it's one of my
favorite coats because I got it in
Wyoming when I was campaigning against
and raising money to beat Liz Cheney and
I was happy to wear it to the State of
the Union last night because it simply
went with my dress so you know I'll
challenge the women on The View anytime
for a debate because they represent the
worst part of America the worst views
and and to be honest with you no one in
my district cares what they think uh I
would imagine that to be true you were
in the hearings today and you may have
had the best line of the day in the
hearing you were talking to the former
Integrity the site Integrity head Joel
Roth and you said quote you permanently
banned my Twitter account but you
allowed child porn all over Twitter
what does that tell tell you
well I think I think Americans should be
extremely concerned about that you know
Hunter Biden's laptop from hell is
exactly what we're investigating on the
oversight committee thanks to Jamie
Comer and many other of my Republican
colleagues and Jim Jordan as well but
you know who else may have a discussing
laptop that's Joel Roth because he's on
record with some very disturbing views
about minors and child porn you know as
as being the the guy in charge of
Twitter and safety he canceled
permanently banned my Twitter account
for a year during my election he
permanently banned president Trump and
many conservative Americans for simply
using their freedom of speech but he
allowed child porn to proliferate on
Twitter to the point where a mother and
her son had to file a lawsuit to get to
get child porn about him and another
minor taken off of Twitter Joel Ross has
a lot to be concerned about and I hope
that we investigate him more all right
congresswoman we're going to follow
these hearings very closely we
appreciate you being with us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else